over the last day
there has been a very interesting
conversation
going on on twitter provoked by this
tweet by
nigel warburton philosophy bites
if you can't say it clearly quit
philosophy that's quite an imperative
there
and it stems from i think if you look at
his account
several other things that he's been
saying
over time and nigel warburton
is is somebody who has an academic
background but then went off on his
own and is you know quite successful as
a podcaster a writer
you know doing doing public philosophy
so it's you know it's not just some
person getting on there and spouting
something forth presumably these are
some
well-considered thoughts and he he
probably didn't just
shoot from the hip as you would say but
deliberately posted this and there were
a lot of responses
as you can see one of the great measures
is quote tweets
those are people who are retweeting it
but they're also saying something above
it and we're going to look at some of
those
there were also many response tweets as
well
and there's a number of likes and i
think you could tell there's a lot of
people who didn't like
that sentiment so i thought it would be
quite interesting to
aggregate some of them i'm not trying to
be totally representative
or say that i'm you know being
systematic or comprehensive but the ones
that i thought were particularly
interesting and on point and to talk
about
those a little bit because this issue of
clarity or
clearly it's not quite so
straightforward as many people
would like to make it out to be so let's
jump
right in
here is a whole set of
most yeah these are all quoted tweets
right
and they they express something that
we can put our finger on so the first
one says
yeah screw learning i guess and this is
really about
how we do in fact learn what is
philosophy like should it just be the
product that we put out there or should
it be
a process so another response oh no my
first attempt at explaining something
wasn't perfect
instead of having people tell me where
i'm being unclear
and improving my own ability to say
something clearly i'm just going to quit
that's a valid response right better
than just screw learning i think
but the screw learning has something to
it another one if you can't say it
clearly
keep doing philosophy with the aim of
increasing clarity again you start to
see this common theme right
maybe doing philosophy
putting stuff out there part of the
natural process
is we go from the less clear to the more
clear
here's another one it's easier to be
clear about questions or topics where
others have already done the work to
make it easy
to say things clearly let's not
discourage work where it's needed most
and that's quite true
if you're doing listicles and you know
the sort of thing that's
sometimes pass is for public philosophy
it's very easy just to aggregate what
other people
have said very clearly already which was
a lot of work on their part to to get
that material to that point
and then to put it out there now here's
a nice thing from
hegel right hegel on saying it clearly
and we'll just look at the things that
that are underlined here
we learn by experience that we meant
something other than we
meant to mean and the correction of our
meaning compels our knowing to go back
to the proposition
and understand it in some other way you
might say well that's unclear
actually it's not i mean that's that's
how in fact we often
do learn anybody who's ever graded
papers and given
commentary or feedback on them and said
well you know this this part needs to be
rethought
and you know maybe you need to place it
in this context knows what we're talking
about here
hagel by the way is often criticized as
one of the writers who's the
least clear right here's another one i
think philosophy works best when there's
a healthy exchange of people putting
wild jumbled ideas into the world
and other people refining clarifying and
synthesizing those ideas
suggesting that there's something like a
division of labor or
functions and that these are
complementary and we don't need to give
sweeping assertions about you know if
you can't do this then just
quit let's move on to the next
interesting
set so here's another
uh angle we can take on it
here's here's one i think my biggest
disagreement with this is the assumption
that clarity
is a property of writing rather than a
property of the relation between the
writing and the reader
yes clarity is not something that
is merely a quality of one's prose
or of the writer him or herself
right and sometimes there's there's
other factors at play this next tweet
shows that two quitters obscurity is
inexcusable on two grounds it may be
deliberately adopted
sorry obscurity is excusable on two
grounds it may be deliberately adopted
as in heraclitus
or the obscurity may be due to the
abstruseness of the subject and not of
the style an instance of this is plato's
timaeus this is cicero talking in
on the ends book two where he
is you know acting as the critic and
you know that's that's a a good thing to
keep in mind this is a point that gets
made over and over again
throughout the history of philosophy
there are some things that are
by their very nature going to be obscure
and require us to really work and work
and work to get them clear
here's another one rather nasty attitude
for lots of reasons but most basically
clarity of thought speech writing is
both a skill
and accomplishment not some innate
essence if you can't say it clearly now
keep working on it and then here's one
there's an exchange that goes on
massimo says that
same mistake as feynman who a lot of
people are big fans of
and and you know post his stuff all the
time some things cannot be said clearly
because
understanding them requires a
significant amount of background
knowledge so clear
is relative to the audience it's
interesting here we're seeing that you
know classical rhetoric
and then whatever we carry forward from
that is
by its very nature attuned to the
audience not
just the subject matter not just the
speaker right
so this is an important set of points
and then here's a final one in this it's
all very well the talk of clarity but
when it becomes an obsession
it's liable to nip living thought in the
bud
friedrich weissman how i see philosophy
so let's look at the next set
these are talking about something that
we've already
touched upon but now we're getting a
little bit deeper into this
many rightly criticizing this tweet but
there's one criticism i have not yet
heard one can neither say nor think what
is not so it's not even possible
to not say it clearly right so
when we get into murky things like
negation or the not or
or nothingness or things like that
there's gonna be some
obscurity involved in those and it's
gonna take us a lot of work to get at at
them
and those are legitimate uh areas and
domains of philosophy here's another one
this is an extremely bad take strive for
clarity sure
but the deepest waters are murky just
try not to drown friends i think there's
a great truth to that
we can as philosophers try to make those
deeper waters
less murky but they're they're usually
going to be
involving some unclarity
even when we get to the very bottom of
them
another one hot take basic observation
about information
some things are more inherently complex
and more incomp
incompressible into simple language than
other things are read with care
use your brain and you won't find
yourself complaining bitterly about
presentation and now that's true it's
not to say that there aren't a lot of
people
writing speaking doing things unclearly
out there but there are complex topics
and there's a mistake in trying to make
things
more simple more clear than they really
ought to be
finally this is right but not for the
reasons they think it is clarity opens
up disparate connections it has nothing
to do
with being easily readable sorry that
philosophy is difficult sometimes bro
you know this is one i have to think
more about um
yeah i do like the idea that clarity
when it's being done
well opens up additional connections it
shouldn't be like
things are clear because i've said the
last word now everyone sit down and shut
up
you know it's but there is a
a you know a real talent to making
things
easily readable i don't think that
easily readable necessarily means
oversimplified or um
leaving things out or you know not using
terminology that people use
let's talk about this next one so a lot
of really good reminders here
don't quit philosophy has diverse
traditions and styles clarity is often
important but be mindful that the
insistence on being clear
without qualification can sometimes
reflect a reluctance to be receptive to
work
that doesn't align with the norms of
one's own tradition and then here's
another great reminder
along these lines clarity looks very
different from the perspectives of
various traditions and how clear you are
can
also just straightforwardly be a matter
of how familiar your audience is with
those traditions
clarity is not a neutral thing nor can
it be attained outside of
a specific context so you know for
example
if you're working within the history of
philosophy
and you you know spend a lot of time a
great example
in my own case with the stoics
when you talk about things like the
indifference right that's a
technical term and it has a certain
meaning and
it requires some unpacking and there's
ways of going
at doing philosophy that
some people might seem very obscure very
uh
you know confused but but can be clear
in that context and we can expand we can
expand this
much more widely you know if you're
reading uh the confucian analytics or
the or the mensis
right and you say oh this is totally
unclear i can't figure out what the
argument is well maybe you need to spend
more time with that
and look at it from within that that
framework here's some more stuff about
this uh specifically focusing on
analytic philosophy it's
it's special to hear this repeated over
and over again by folks whose ordinary
language
analytic philosophical project is best
represented by wittgenstein's aphorisms
do what you say and quit this claim
itself if
is not clear if you stay in philosophy
after repeating it right
and then just going to say some analytic
philosophers have a weird understanding
of what clarity is
don't throw at me what about it
continentals in the comments couldn't
care less about them either
but that's the story for another tweet
and i think that's quite right there is
a
fetishization of clarity which you know
like
all uh sort of faith commitments
typically involves not looking too
carefully and closely at
what's actually meant by the liturgical
language
uh and i think that there is something
to that that said the continental
philosophy does contain a lot of
deliberately obscure stuff which when
you untangle it doesn't doesn't end up
meaning anything but that's not to say
all continental is like that
but here's a great example of turning
this on its head by referring to a
specific
philosophical tradition clear and
distinct perceptions or
gtfo now who's that referring to the
entire cartesian tradition
where it's not about language and
expressing yourself clearly
that way it's about clarity in your mind
defined in terms of having clear and
distinct
conceptions or perceptions and you know
when you read descartes
um there's there's some work that's
required because it's not always totally
clear let's move on to
another set of responses now here we get
turning it back on itself this demand
you know if you can't say it clearly
quit philosophy
and so people say this is a remarkably
unclear and speculative statement
funnily enough and and that's true
because
what's it what's clearly you know um
another one the meaning of this
statement is of course not entirely
clear
and then for example that we get down to
a little bit more granular
areas if starting a statement with if
then follow the if clause with a then
clause to establish a relationship
between the two clauses as a further
example
always clearly establish an antecedent
prior to using a pronoun so
you know like with a lot of really
lapidary statements of philosophy
if you turn this on itself it fails by
its own criteria
then they turn this on to nigel
warburton himself if you can't state
your recommendations for would-be
philosophers without assuming that
what's clear to you is clear to others
then quit making such recommendations so
there's the quitting there and then
this tweet lacks clarity i guess he
should quit
philosophy so you know there's
this is kind of an interesting way of
turning things on its head
and actually nigel uh warburton
responded to
one of these um in in a way that that's
quite revealing i would say so the
here's the the quote
i'm sorry i don't quite understand what
you're saying any chance you could
clarify
and then he says obscurantist nine donka
you know meaning
uh no thanks i'm i'm not going to engage
with you although i will engage with you
enough to say
this thing right here so when given the
opportunity to clarify what he means i
suppose by it or clarifying
or quitting or philosophy he
he just you know gave this response
instead
here's another one uh also you know
bringing up some perhaps inconsistency
this is the guy that literally
used erazio recta and erazio obliquia
in a tweet defending himself on
accusations of transphobia so you know
i'm a little reluctant to say oh if
you're not totally consistent then
you know you have to be quiet and get
out of here because that seems
rather unfair to me but you know
is our practice completely consistent
when it comes to this
sort of demand for clarity i don't know
here's another set of important
reminders
um tell that to plato aristotle hegel
heidegger kant all the other germans
machiavelli montesquiou lac cicero
xenophon um okay that's
an important group and we could expand
it much more widely there's
every one of these has some parts that
are not immediately
intuitively evident in their writings
they're maybe not as unclear as some
people make them out to be
but uh you know it's um you know they do
require work and here's another
great example that that nigel warburton
responded to
clarity is a philosophical virtue but
any necessary condition that would
exclude drungza
laozi narghajuna dogan heraclitus
aristotle spinoza leibniz kant hegel
schopenhauer kierkegaard and nietzsche
and wittgenstein from the practice is
clearly an unreasonable one
and nigel's response which is a good
response i think it's probably too late
for any of these to quit
so he's indexing his thing to us in the
present
uh here's another great one so if i need
to read a supplemental text or
introduction to get a clear
understanding of what a philosopher was
saying they should have quit
all right okay got it another one this
kind of conflation of the love of wisdom
with the love of logic is like in
the astronomer who thinks math makes the
sun rise that's a
pretty good analogy i would say there
and then finally some of my favorite
philosophers are luminously clear
others much less so let a thousand
flowers bloom meaning you know why do we
need to insist
on clarity for every single philosopher
in every single
case here's another set of very
important concerns that we've mentioned
a little bit earlier but now
are brought to the fore in these two
tweets
does anyone have a useful working
definition of what clarity and
philosophy is
why should clarity whatever that is
trump other philosophical virtues
why believe from the outset that
philosophical truths can be expressed
clearly don't want to dunk just genuine
questions
and then finally i get that this is
maybe tongue-in-cheek but i think more
practitioners need to look at the
ideology of clarity here
who is defining what clarity is what
does it look like
what does it involve why is it necessary
and who is holding that position
these are some very very important
questions i don't think they have to be
roadblocks where we say oh well clarity
until we can answer these questions
throw it out the window it doesn't
matter at all
but we shouldn't you know take clarity
or clearness or whatever we're going to
use as synonyms for this
as being itself inherently
clear if we do we're probably
screwing things up in some ways we we
really
need to think through at least at least
through a couple steps
these questions you know what is clarity
um
why should it be made so important
compared to other philosophical virtues
there are there are other things that
matter in philosophy who gets to decide
what counts as clarity are there some
philosophical truths that might not be
able to be expressed clearly
you know these are really serious
questions that we need to
explore rather than just assume answered
there's a few uh tweets where we've got
nigel responding to them
and i think the response is we don't
have to make too much of these but
they're they're interesting so one
person says foe intellectual
anti-intellectualism is alive and well i
see
and then he responds i've never claimed
to be an intellectual i'm a writer i
think that's kind of disingenuous
because you know obviously
a writer is part of the intelligentsia
and he's writing about philosophy
itself so so it's a good sort of
off-the-cuff response
i don't think it answers it is this
really though faux intellectual
anti-intellectualism i think that's
probably
uh going too far in the accusations this
next one bad air bad air now obviously
if you know your literature that is a
reference to nietzsche's genealogy of
morals
and the discussion about how values
false values are created
and risantomont so i think what he's
doing is he's claiming that this is
an example of resantamont or the you
know slave morality or something like
that
and then nigel responds by saying air or
hair do i have you know bad air here or
bad hair
again really a non-response but you know
an example of wit
um now this one's a bit more interesting
if you can't say anything nice don't say
anything at
all being used as a response to nigel
warburton telling people they should
quit doing philosophy
and you know nigel's response here is
actually
a pretty good one that tweet undermines
itself right
because maybe this dictum if you can't
say anything nice don't say
anything at all i should have you know
had this response when i was a kid
that's self-defeating right because it's
not really nice to tell people that they
can only talk about nice things
or maybe it is niceness in a you know
meta nice level i don't know
but that's something definitely worth
worth thinking about
um and then finally here's here's
another one
if it can't be because if it can't be
put as a bullet point on a powerpoint
slide
it's not a true point and then nigel
says
interestingly enough no because life is
short now
when i read that i was like okay i often
say life is short
but i don't use that as a
reason to demand that everybody be
totally clear all the time
i do use it sometimes to say hey what
are what are you getting at you know
you've got
a limited sliver of my time what are you
actually trying to say
in conversations um but they don't have
to be necessarily
bullet pointed it seems like he's kind
of endorsing this if you can't say it
you know
very briefly because he had another
tweet where he said something like that
if you can't sum up your philosophy and
you know basically an elevator pitch
it's not very good at all
um i think that there's a lot of cases
where i would be like life is short so i
need to spend the time to figure out
what the hell nietzsche is actually
saying here or hegel's saying here i
mean think about the
half hour hegel videos that i make right
i i've got maybe another if i'm really
really really lucky
30 years or 40 years left of life
and this is what i spend my time on
right so
i don't know this life is short response
i think that can go a lot of different
ways so you can say there's an ambiguity
there as as well now here's the last two
and i think these are in some respect
the best responses altogether so the
first one
the speaker is speaking can you hear the
sound the listener is listening as he
hits the ground the medium or the
message but there's no one around i
couldn't believe i couldn't believe the
stars of war burton were waiting for me
so reference to a song i think if i
remember right
and that's kind of clever but this one
is the absolute best
my prose is so clear people see
right through it now there's some
intentional ambiguity
there on a literal level you know
obviously if your prose was so clear
that people can see
right through it there would be no pros
because they'd be seeing the blank page
or the blank website or whatever it
happens to be right they can't see
the things that stand out but you know
if we think about what it means to be
so clear you know as as meeting some
ideal
that people see right through it it
could be that people see exactly what my
motives are
people see through it in the sense of
they're like well this is [ __ ] and i
can see that it's
[ __ ] you know when we talk about
people seeing through
somebody else's statements that's
usually what we
mean and so this is a this is a really
clever one it's saying
i'm gonna say that i meet your ideal
so well that people can see that what
i'm doing is no good
and so that i think that's a very clever
uh response the most clever response out
of all of them that i've seen
so there's clearly a lot to think about
people are going to say well you know
hey what's your position
on this clearness thing i think i've
given you a few hints about that but i
i have a lot more to think about this
myself
to maul over to reflect this is not
something that is
by itself totally clear to me
and i think that you know we we do have
the
whatever you want to call it the freedom
the leisure
the luxury the right to not have to take
a stand on this immediately
and to think it through a bit so that's
about as much as
i am willing to contribute
on this this matter hopefully you've
enjoyed reading through these you might
go to the
original tweet which i'll put a link to
in the
video description and if you have takes
on
on this position go ahead and leave them
in the comments and uh yeah we'll we'll
just go
from there i'm sure that in the days
ahead this is this is a
tweet that is not going to go away
and there will probably be a lot of
other interesting responses to it
as well
you